for
e
that's what it
is right good evening
everybody Welcome to the final cabinet
meeting of
2023 fire alarm procedures if the fire
alarm is activated vate the offices VI
the stairs please do not use the lifts
assembl in hly square on the green
officers will assist you and advise when
it's Teem safe to return to the
chamber please switch off or turn to
silent your mobile phones do not make or
receive me meeting calls while the
meeting is in progress please note this
meeting is being live streamed for
members of the public the meeting will
also be recorded and be subsequently
available on the internet does anybody
intend to film the
meeting the following members have asked
speak under Council procedure rule 20.1
item five councelors p and bayford item
six councelor Rogers and rattigan and
councelor 7even item seven councelor Pew
councelor 7
councelor scobby just wanted to speak
under item on Jackie Bakers please
chair
six C six and seven please
chair okay thank
you
uh everybody's here so there are no
apologies is there any Declarations of
interest in the item business on the
agenda this evening no minutes to the
previous meeting on the 16th of November
2023 copies attached to the agenda pack
propos you take the minutes as R do I
have a second up councilor Yates members
agree agree thank you so we move on to
item four which is the combined
surveillance CTV image recording
Technologies policy councilor kee
thank you CCTV and the use of image
recording is now commonplace from Town
Center CCTV cameras to building security
dash cams ring doorbells and mobile
phones the council's use of CCTV is
governed by a profusion of legislation
codes of practice and central government
guidance news and new and emerging
Technologies and capabilities such as
artificial intelligence biome metrics or
advances in it system integration must
be considered as an increased risk to
individual privacy and the council must
ensure that it continues to be compliant
in response the council has developed
this policy which is intended to
regulate the council's operation and use
of image recording systems across all
areas of the council including when and
where CCTV is used cabinet is being
asked to agree the adoption of combined
surveillance CCTV image recording
Technologies policy and to delegate any
operational revisions of the policy to
the heads of neighborhood
so thank
you thank you councilor Kean d a
second thank you councelor Yates
members nothing to add okay thank you is
that agreed agreed thank you
[Music]
right moving on to item five the
purchase of 24 Homes at totle Street
Minster for affordable rent councelor
Whitehead thank you leader tonight
cabinet is being asked to agree to
firstly the purchase of 24 new
affordable homes using the additional
capital budget approved by council at
its meeting on 12th of October
2023 and the letting of these homes in
accordance with the council's
allocations policy at an affordable rent
as set out in the council's teny
strategy earlier this year officers were
contacted by BDW Barrett's homes who are
required to deliver 24 new affordable
homes as part of their development at
tothill Street in Minster the
requirement for these homes is set out
in the section 106 obligations for the
development they have been unable to
secure an affordable housing provider to
deliver these homes which would put 24
affordable homes at risk of Disappearing
if a provider were not
found in July this year Council approved
an accelerated affordable rented housing
program of at least 400 new homes
constructed or acquired by
2027 these properties progress towards
this total which currently stands at 123
properties acquired or in progress
within the first four months of this
strategy the capital cost for the 24
homes is 3.2 million with £50,000 for
cost Associated
costs as the homes have been designated
as affordable homes in the planning
consent and section 106 agreement they
have been designed specifically for that
purpose and accordingly are considered
appropriate for the HRA in line with the
needs of households on the council's
register or those living in temporary
accommodation there is a significant
level of Need for one-bedroom homes on
our housing list as well as for larger
family
homes the unit sizes and the mix of
homes are as follows eight one bed units
and 16 twoed
units it is proposed that the new homes
are let in accordance with the council's
adopted allocations policy on a
genuinely affordable rent set out with
our ten within our tendency
strategy as discussed in detail
previously all potential Acquisitions
are considered by Finance within a
robust business plan outline no project
will be brought forward if it is
considered to not be a good investment
for the portfolio or represents
excessive
risk our options are as follows option
3.1 to approve the purchase of 24
section 106 units and delegate authority
to officers to conclude the due
diligence and complete the purchase or
3.2 do not purchase the section 106
units which would mean that the
developer would negotiate a commuted sum
losing the affordable housing
units these homes are far more than
figures they have the capacity to change
lives create stability both for
individuals and for our larger housing
market and enable us to further grow our
ability to provide secure housing for
residents through Revenue
generation I move recommendation 3.1 for
the purchase of homes that stand to make
a huge difference to our residents
thank
you thank you councelor Whitehead can I
have a second please councelor Alan and
speaking another 20.1 councelor
Pew thank you chair and thank you
councelor wad uh for introducing this um
I'd first like to say that as the
previous Ward counselor for the fanet
villages I know that this development uh
wider development is incredibly
unpopular with residents but the one
thing that wasn't unpopular was the
affordable housing that would be brought
forward um and I'm delighted to see the
Quantum of the affordable is what was
agreed under the previous plan
application because that was uh through
conversations with the developer and
with Minster Paris Council about the
need for these smaller units these one
two-bedroom units CU they're actually
what is harder for people who need to to
live in affordable housing that's the
real kind of shortage particularly in
The Villages um what I am concerned
about is uh not us bailing out
developers or anything like that I
appreciate if there's not um any housing
associations that want to take this on
it makes sense for us to do that
100% but I suppose from my own
experience um I know that a lot of
developers quite like having some
affordable housing within a development
because normally the housing
associations pay for those units upfront
before they're built in Fall um and that
then helps them to effectively fund more
of the development build so they can
build more of the units before they sell
them so my only question really is is
that this pay
if it is agreed tonight will it be made
in full now or is there a certain point
where it will be handed over to
developer upon completion of the units
um that's just all what I really want to
to understand so thank
you thank you councelor P that's an
interesting question do you want to
respond councelor white of course thank
you councelor
Pew I think for me especially in terms
of more contentious developments as you
were saying the one thing that we all
generally agree on is that it's the
affordable units that we need the
delivery model that we have is
effectively determined by central
government
we have a delivery system that provides
affordable housing only through those
developments or through councils
choosing to
invest and build our own stock both of
which we do here
so the only real option I see in terms
of what we do now is to take on the take
on the affordable units because a
commuted sum simply doesn't provide what
we actually need which is the housing
especially in areas where it's
particularly difficult to afford such as
Minster um at the moment as far as I'm
aware we're still within the due
diligence and contract negotiation point
but I'm happy to pass on to the lovely
Ashley um if she has further information
on the
timetable thank you um so we haven't
agreed uh these haven't even started on
site these units probably as you're
aware we haven't agreed the purchase the
units that we've bought um we're in the
process of buying it's a bit far green
we've done a turnkey Arrangement so
we're paying on completion so they're
handing them over then we're paying um
we we could do this with this site or we
could do a development agreement where
we do make stage payments but we haven't
discussed that with barretts um at all
at the
moment okay thank you do you have
anything further to say cast
wi yeah 123
homes other than that no thank
you thank you uh councilor
bord thank you chair thank you councelor
white um yeah I I very much welcome the
purchase of these affordable homes
particularly the smaller units which as
you said very much need I'm interested
to know um as we are acquiring them from
the start are we able to influence the
Energy Efficiency of the homes and
consequently the EPC rating thank
you thank you councelor raford um yes
LLY um so what we're doing at the moment
considering the strategy that we're
taking forward is putting together a
specification that we would like from
developers so currently we have our own
specification that we work work to
relating to our builds which obviously
we have a large degree of control over
what we would like to be doing is
producing a specification so that for
purchases that we are making early on in
the process we have the ability to work
with developers on producing housing
that matches what we would like to see
within housing stock overall um but a
lot of the the specification s that
we're looking at currently in terms of
procurement are very high it's been
lovely seeing the standard of a lot of
the builds developing so far so yes we
do have a specification in the pipeline
currently so
that hopefully we can continue building
housing stock that we're incredibly
proud of thank
you um so does that mean will these
homes be EPC wise be um
in in the sorry same rating as the rest
of the estate or will it are our homes
specific so each each development is
different but
simultaneously developers are held to
particular standards when they are
producing housing so our generally is to
get to EPC B um I think if I pass over
to Ash I'm not sure what we have on the
ones that we produced thus
far uh yeah so um so like you said these
are in early stages so we will we have
got specification to influence them um
the units on the Spitfire green
obviously we're already uh built our own
development will be um epca so they'll
be um very low carbon homes um but yeah
we will do as much as we can to
influence the EPC on these These are at
least C so we'll work on them yeah yeah
minimum yeah but like these are in early
stages and our specification will inform
them thank you counc
Beford members any comments
questions okay so um it's been moved and
seconded that we agree the purchase of
24 wat new affordable homes using the
additional capital budget approved by
Council on the 12th of October and the
letting of these homes in accordance
with the council's allocation policy at
an affordable rent as out in the
council's teny strategy do members
agree thank
you item six Jackie Bakers Recreation
ground councelor
Alber indeed it is indeed it is
um uh this report to uh cabinet sets out
the proposals uh for for approval for
improvements at Jackie Baker's
Recreation ground in
Ramsgate uh the report refers to a
petition that was received by the
council in June about uh the management
of Jackie Baker's Recreation ground and
describes the actions taken since
then the recommendations include or were
to include that the the demolition of
the existing Pavilion subject to
planning approval but I'm pleased to
advise me members that planning consent
was approved last night um which is a a
great step forward um following the
demolition uh of this building it's
proposed that temporary facilities are
provided with Team changing room showers
officials changing storage and
toilets uh the report also proposes the
adoption of a master plan which can be
found at Annex one of the
report for the future development of the
site the master plan proposals are not
currently funded but the adoption of the
plan will informed Direction and
represent a first step towards securing
the required funding for the long-term
future of Jackie
Bakers the report further proposes uh
that Authority be delegated to
investigate the options uh for a future
de development on the site based on the
master plan including car parking
a new Pavilion and other sporting
recreational facilities that might
enhance the offer at the
site uh a further report uh will be
presented to the overview and scrutiny
panel and the cabinet once this uh
options have been uh further explored um
I would add at this point that um
obviously what's we would also be going
out to uh the public for during a
consultation
for their uh views on the um on the on
the master
plan um I would also say that um that at
overviewing scrutiny um the members of
the committee uh came up with um three
uh proposals uh of which I'm pleased to
uh take on board uh which are as follows
um that wording is added to
recommendation
C uh as follows approves a public
engagement exercise to inform the master
planning of Jackie Bakers uh based on uh
section one of the draft master plan
attached to at Annex
one two that the council explores
facilities that will be installed that
will encourage safe enjoyment of Jackie
Bakers by girls and young women
and three to ensure the temporary
changing facilities are properly insured
and secured and that's the no-brainer
anyway we would we would do that as a as
a matter of course um so therefore uh
leader I uh proposed the
recommendations as laid out within the
report um and also the um requirements
laid down by o overview and scrutiny
thank
you thank you counc alurn do you have a
second councelor
Dorth and speaking under 20.1 councelor
Rogers thank you leader thank you
councelor Orbin I'm pleased to see the
investment in Jackie Bakers for the
benefit of all users on this site um my
query is on 2. 2.2 b a review of the
bins on the site has been completed but
there's um no mention of of have we got
extra bins that people were complaining
about
um what's the outcome please and the
other point is the housing plan States
um the house is a three-bedroom up to
five people but there's only space for
one car sure um I don't think we're
considering the housing tonight counc
okay um I appreciate I appreciate the
master plan but that will go to planning
okay thank you
thanks
um I haven't been advised of whether the
extra bins have been put in um I've
asked for that um I'm not sure if
uh Mr M would be able to answer that
thank you thank you counselor um I'm
advised by um the head of cleansing that
a review was done of the placement of
the bins and that actually the bins were
in the right locations they haven't as
of yet added any further bins and
they're monitoring the scenarios that
are going on at Jackie Bakers to see if
there are there is an alternate location
that where a bin is needed so they're
doing reviews uh every week on that at
the
moment thank you uh councelor rattigan
thank you very much um just a question
regard to um C album uh the cost of
deiss seems sort of rather High uh just
want to know how how you sort of come by
them figures uh given sort the national
average is about 115 per square meter um
and if there's if the whole site was
covered in asbest normally that's about
55 square meter on top it's comeing even
with that it's coming to about 100
thousand and we've got a figure about
quarter of a million pound I'm just
concerned where that figures come from
in See's quite High um yeah I think we
did have a discussion about that
scrutiny from what I can remember but
I'm sure that we can revisit it do you
want to speak on that Mr
nor thank you chair um yeah you're right
we what we've done is we've um done a um
internal uh survey of the site um there
is asbestos on the site which we've
added a a premium on um there's also um
utility specs that are for full flood
lighting of the site which were never
introduced and that utility spec is very
high which is also going to need to be
removed um So based on that we have put
the um the demolition costs a level that
we think is the maximum it can be um we
are currently seeking um quantity surve
final
analysis as part of the procurement
exercise to get the contractor for the
demolition if this was approved tonight
so as it stands at the moment we've done
an internal survey and and put it at a
level that we think is the highest it
possibly could
be thank you councelor
scobby yeah thank you chair um and thank
you councelor Orin for your sort of
introduction it sort of answered one of
the questions cuz one of the reasons I
wanted to speak under this was I wasn't
clear on the report where and being
relatively new counselor how
recommendations from over and scrutiny
came to Cabinet um but you sort of have
covered that point I know you were um
watching it um so I I guess I'm just as
one of the ward counselors just
welcoming the work that's been put into
this thankful to the cabinet for moving
this um I did have a a question um based
on your comments Council and then just
one from um the officer talking about
bins so um you mentioned that there will
be a report coming back at a future over
you in scrutiny and cabinet um I'm
assuming that's going to be um difficult
to put time scales on but do we have a
rough idea of um weeks months years and
then secondly um consultation we've
referred to when are we likely that that
to start and then specifically to
officer about the bins take clearly take
the point around um not moving the bins
as they are they're in good positions
but I think part of it was also would
more bins help um because there's two
bins for a place that size um and I
think one of the things that will be
changing in the future is the amount of
throughput traffic because new houses
new development um had schools new
schools placed there um I think in the
future there's going to need to be more
bins and it may be um I'm I'm surprised
in the review that wasn't covered but
maybe maybe more more detail was covered
thank you
chair yeah thank you Council scobby
um in in relation to the further report
um that's going to be uh relative to the
master plan so uh that's going to be uh
I can't give you a rough rough idea
about that I think we will we will try
and go out to um consultation as soon as
soon as we can because we obviously we
want the feedback from the local
residents of what they want and the you
and the people who use it uh want um
because the master plan covers quite a
number of different sports and it's
whether those Sports will be available
you know whether they will be taken up
so we need to get whatever money that we
get and we that we can spend on this
that we need to ensure that whatever
facilities we provide are going to be
taken up and used and I think that's
that's important part I think as well
uh in relation to the binge I think um
as as Mr Mamo said you know we are
currently mon monitoring that and
monitoring the use of them um to see you
know whether there is any more needed
and and and that will come in due in in
due calls and if there is more than
happy to to put extra ones in there um
but I I I think that
um once once we get the residents in in
involved it will it'll open up uh the
consultation and we'll be able to give a
uh A Better Way Forward and I think a
part of those uh
consultations that we're going to take
the housing out of that consultation
because it is a separate matter to the
actual ground there did I answer
everything or not thank
you councelor
Austin thank you chair and thanks
Council Ain um I wanted to repeat what I
said at scrutiny which is it's really
excellent to see a response to the
petition that residents brought coming
forward so promptly and so clearly and
that there's going to be residents
consultation informing this my question
is about how we're going to balance up
what we're doing here with what there is
elsewhere in thanet as we know we've got
a number of Parks and Recreation areas
desperately in need of further injection
of of um facilities and money and
whether um now we have new Open Spaces
senior staff in place whether we're
thinking of doing a a broader strategy
which looks at how we're going to divide
um our Attention our funds our work in
the future across the area and I'm
thinking in relation to that
particularly of um what you mentioned
earlier um Council Alban Joan Bright's
um very welcome intervention about
making sure that all of these facilities
are welcoming and appropriate and safe
spaces for young women and girls thank
you um I think uh there's quite a broad
you've come with quite a broad brush
there across uh Open Spaces effectively
and I I think as far as um if I just say
as far as Jackie Bakers is
concerned uh
it's there's been no money if you like
put into Jackie Bakers for a long long
time and it's and it's a place it's a
big area it's well used and and it needs
that's the first one um we hopefully
have got our Open Spaces manager
starting in February so that'll be a big
a big boost um what we'll be looking at
as well we've got as you as you're aware
we have a section 106 officer so a lot
of those parts open and play areas and
stuff we'll be looking to ensure that
that money goes into those areas and and
and and done but um I'm I'm sure um once
our open man spaces manager come comes
in uh Mr MMA be obviously working
closely with him is it is it
he and um and you know the the the work
will be planned out so which obviously
we've lost we've lost that for quite
some some time so effectively open space
has lost its way a bit so um we're
hoping to drag that back in and then we
can and then we can work on and we we
we're looking at I mean if it's me look
at the worst ones first and and try and
do them and the better ones need you
know then they can get worse before we
all right thank you
thanks right members um I've got a
question unusually um I'd wonder if um
Mr MMO can give us any idea of the time
scales in terms of the demolition of the
The Pavilion and the temporary portal
cabin for Cy because I think we are
concerned about the safety of the
existing building um and I appreciate
that the um the funding has to be
approved by Council but I think that the
time scale for de demolishing the
building isn't necessarily limited by
that so could you say when you think
that we'll be in a position to demolish
The
Pavilion
um as soon as we've got um approval to
uh spend the funding we will then go
through a procurement excise with the
contractor and that procument exercise
will take something from sort of 3
months roughly around about to to
achieve uh a signed contractor then it's
down to the contractor's mobilization
period um and and we would hope that
would be a month to two months the
actual demolition of the building can
can be done quite rapidly um the key
thing that we need to make sure and get
a time scale on is the utilities part
because that's a bit where we're relying
on um certain contractors that do have
um lead in Scales so I would like to
think that the full demolition would
would take roughly a month to do add
that to the um the sort of three months
leading for procurement and the
mobilization time hopefully will be
demolished within six-month period
I mean I think it's quite important that
the residents understand that because
they'll see us make a decision but if
they don't see anything happen and they
think the time scales are different from
what we might like and that can lead to
lead to disappointment and speculation
that we've changed their mind which we
haven't and won't I think chair if I
just come back on that I I think um one
of one of the the good things that's
that's come out of this is that the rort
between the Reg who put the petition in
myself and with Mr Maro is very very
good and we you know we contact each
other so they I let them know what's
going on and whatever as I will probably
tomorrow with this so keep them up to
speed with it
all and I think that obviously the
master plan is is fantastic but we've
actually got to deliver on it and that
that's the challenge that faces us but I
think in terms of Jackie Bakers because
of its central location and because of
the size of it it's an opportunity for
it to be a a flagship facility for the
council so taking on board what council
Austin said about other places needing
money which it certainly does but I
don't think we should be afraid of
putting a focus on Jackie Bakers and
getting that right and showing what we
can do um and that's going to you know
there's more work ahead in order to make
that possible members any other
discussion councelor
Keem thank you leader yes like councilor
Austin I was really pleased to hear that
it was going to Encompass the needs for
safety for women and girls in open
spaces and I look forward to that being
a consideration in future developments
of a similar
type thank you any
others no right I'm going to read the
recommendations because I think that
it's important that we're clear what
we're agreeing to and in this case there
there are quite a few um so uh we're
agreeing to approve the demolition of
the existing Pavilion on the basis of
health and safety approve the purchase
of a temporary portter cabin style
changing for facility once demolition
has occurred approve a public engagement
exercise to inform the master planning
of Jackie Bakers based on section one of
the master plan attached to anex Annex
one delegate authority to the chief
executive to investigate the options for
a future development on the site based
on the master plan to include a new car
park new Pavilion to include changing
facilities and other sporting
recreational facilities that might
enhance the offer at the site with the
report to be presented to the overview
of scrutiny panel and cabinet once these
options have been further explored that
the council explores facilities that
will be installed that will encourage
safe enjoyment of Jackie Bakers by girls
and young women and to ensure the
temporary changing facilities are
properly insured and secured and finally
to recommend to council a oneof 2324
supplementary general fund Revenue
budget of 370,000 be approved for the
demolition of the existing Pavilion and
the provision of a temporary pool to
cabin facility to be funded from the
risk preserve is that agreed members
agre thank you
and we move on to item seven which is
public toilets refurbishment and renewal
project which is also Council Alm yeah I
get all the good
ones um okay uh this report proposes a
schedule of investment in public toilets
around the district uh budgets total in
1.25 million with a mixture of Revenue
and capital funding have been
identified a further sum of 250,000
is anticipated although not yet approved
via an external Grant from Southern
water uh the report proposes maintenance
works at seven
sites this will focus on addressing
existing defects and is not a full
refurbishment of the
toilets but it will return them to a
much higher standard of repair examples
of the work content can be found at
Annex one with the estimated
cost the total spend on the review uh
review of the
total the total spend on Revenue repair
work is 279,000 and subject uh to
approval at cabinet it is proposed to
undertake these works in the new year so
that they are complete before the start
of the 2024
season the report also proposes Capital
works at three sites marget Clock Tower
Stone Bay and botony Bay these Capital
Works will provide significantly
improved and accessible facilities at
all three
sites there are currently 27 public
toilets in thanet and this report
proposes Works in 10 of those 27
locations this investment is proposed to
be the start of an anticipated wider and
longer term program of public toilet
improvements subject to further funding
being
identified the report also proposes that
a further uh report be taken to Cabinet
before the end of October
2024 to provide an update on toilet
refurbishment and Improvement works the
report will update on the capital Works
program and we will propose next steps
to address refurbishment or improvements
at the public toilets not included in
this initial
phase £400,000 of Revenue funding is
coming from earmarked
reserves in option one 279,000 will be
allocated for Revenue repairs and
121,000 revenue contribution to Capital
however it will uh if we are required to
undertake option two uh then the whole
of the 400 ,000 will be allocated to
revenue
repairs the cabinet is
recommending to council that a oneoff
supplementary general fund Revenue
budget of £ 279,000 be approved for the
repairs to existing facilities to be
funded from the underspend identified at
the end of
2022 to 23 and allocated to be eart
reserves for investment in toilet
facilities uh of the
$749,000 budget for the public toilets
refurbishment and renewal project within
the 2324 Capital program the report
suggests £450,000 is coming from
borrowing and
121,000 contribution is coming from eart
reserves with financing of the remaining
179,000 to be identified at a later
date
£400,000 of funding will be from Margate
Town deal funding which is an external
Grant cabinet notes that £400,000 of
approved capital budget is allocated for
soet facilities within the Margate Town
deal scheme in the 2324 Capital uh
program it is estimated that southern
water will allocate funding to the value
of £250,000
as uh said
earlier
um again overviewing
scrutiny uh came up with uh a
recommendation and uh which again I'm
happy to uh take on board and hope the
cabinet will as well uh and that is that
the Western undercliffe public toilets
be added to the list of toilets for
consideration when further funding
becomes
available um so therefore chair I
propose to recommendation in the in the
report and to add the uh item from
overview and
scrutiny thank you councelor you have a
second councelor D
with I think councelor Pew was first on
20.1 oh thank you chair you spoil me um
maybe it's the festive season and I'm
feeling quite Jolly um but I've got to
be honest chair and I've got to be
honest councelor Orin uh I really
welcome this I think it's uh much needed
it's a long time coming uh particularly
for not just any of our public toilets
but particularly some of the coastal
toilets when you think of many of the
visitors uh to the district uh that come
to the beaches and of course some of the
state of uh disrepair that our toilets
are in I think it's probably one of The
Thirst things that they see um you know
and and and we need to do better um
unfortunately councelor C can't be here
tonight I know we all know that he was
incredibly excited about public toilets
when we were in administration
and it's all he ever used to talk about
when councelor orb so he probably spoke
to you about it as well um so I know
that he would yeah always always um you
know so I know that he would welcome
this as well um my only kind of concern
or question would be and and this may
have been brought up overviewing
scrutiny and I apologize if I'm
repeating a question that was already um
put uh put to you then or or when they
were scrutinizing this but considering
that the majority of the toilets
included within the first phase are
coastal toilets and under the previous
administration we were looking at
proposals for uh your leisure to take on
the coastal toilets not just the ones
that are open now but some of the ones
that have been long closed including the
ones down at the crabing pool in Mis Bay
which you know if you spoke to some
residents half the residents remember
those toilets and half of them didn't
know they were there until you told them
they were there and they're now closed
and now suddenly they want them reopened
so you know it was a quite an expanded
offer and they were not just going to
take on the upkeep uh and running of
coastal toilets but try and reopen or
rovide more provision as well so my
question would be particularly as this
first phase is taken up with a lot of
coastal toilets is has that been
progressed or if it's not why not mainly
because I think it would still be quite
an interesting proposal if it can be
pulled off because it would mean that
council's finances could go into
supporting or refurbishing and providing
more provision in our town centers which
let's be honest when we want more of our
residents and visitors to visit our town
center and spend money and keep the high
streets going one of the complaints that
uh that I have from residents not just
from burington but when they go to
shoping to Margate or bres or Ramsgate
is that there's very limited public
toilets provision so a lot of them if
they need to go to the toilet they they
really struggle um so that was that was
my question
really do you want to ask for that cast
yeah yeah I just
yeah um I just want to be clear was your
question about your leisure or was it
about the because you mentioned your
your leisure first was it in relation to
that or was it related to the second
part of what you were saying in about
the town censes uh Council Orin it was
kind of both so it was kind of if uh if
the your your leisure would take on more
the coastal toilets we could provide now
more provision and more repairs to the
High Street toilets uh but of course
they're important as well in general
yeah well um we are still talking to
your leisure to see whether or or or not
it what is what is VI is
viable and um I'm not sure how far we've
progressed with that to to be quite
honest I must admit I haven't talked
about that for a while um but I do know
the officers uh have advised me that
they are talking uh to your leisure to
see whether they can take some over will
take some over uh have the where we all
to actually do that um so that that is
in progress as far as I'm aware um
you're right about uh our town centers
and they are important especially I know
from Ramsgate when the Town Center
toilet was closed here because of
antisocial behavior and Drug taking and
God knows what else there that it they
it was heavily missed if pardon the it
was heavily missed by the by the
residents especially the elderly
residents who come into town um but I
think what we what we've done with this
part of the report now is
identified effectively what what are the
worst to and and on the coast so we can
welcome our residents and our our res
and our visitors to there to be actually
do that but certainly the next trance I
think that is what we'll be looking at
um so um that's it thank CH yeah I mean
as it happens um Council P I've had a
conversation with the chief exec about
that that very subject this morning and
I think um the reality is there's more
work to be done on it we certainly
haven't ruled it out but we'd have to be
satisfied that it offers value for money
because as you know your leisure aren't
offering to take on the toilets as a
charitable uh offer there would be a
quid pro quo so we'd have to understand
how that Stacks up financially um it's
not something we've we've ruled in or
out but we will be looking at it further
um and I think the main priority for us
has been making sure there are some
Works done before mix season on the
toilets that most urgently need them and
we can do that through the current
refurbishment budget um I think the
other challenge which we're all well
aware of is that there is concern about
the opening hours which are not always
entirely predictable um for residents
who want to use the toilets and I think
we want to look at ways if there are
ways that we can do better and your
leisure might be part of that or they
might not be part of that but there's
more work to be done but we certainly
haven't dismissed it as an
idea yeah yeah would you give my regards
to count counselor cup and tell him I'm
happy to see him at any toilet he wishes
to you tell I'm sure he will appreciate
that sounds really inappropriate
councelor Orin um I will send him your
best in a Merry Christmas that's what
I'll
do councelor Austin thank you chair and
thanks Council auin um in in our corner
of the chamber we greatly welcome this
this is excellent and we're really
pleased to see um the scrutiny
recommendation of adding the Western
Undercliff toilets to uh to the list
because as you know Ramsgate Town
Council we ended up um putting some of
our council's allowances into making
sure that the were poter lose there um
during this last summer season which
were extremely well looked after and
dealt with entirely respectfully by
bathers Etc so they were they were a
really welcome facility um I wanted to
ask going back to councelor Cup's
specialist subject um I know one of the
things that he was talking about um as a
possibility in the mix for our public
toilets in the future was partnership
work with local businesses is that off
the agenda now with this Administration
or is that still under consideration
thank
you uh I haven't discussed that at all
uh be totally Frank um something maybe
that that that we should be looking at
to see whether we can get any uh local
businesses prepared to invest on that I
um
I I think that's something Council atin
would be happy to to
discuss um and and I'll come back to you
on that I'm pretty happy
to am am I okay to come back on that um
I was just thinking about it in in terms
of as you know with Ramsgate Town
Council with our climate change group
we're looking at um adopting the refill
scheme to encourage pubs and cafes and
so on to allow people to go in and and
fill their bottle of water and it felt
to me like that was a sort of beginning
of a discussion with some of the local
Coastal businesses about you know other
facilities that they might be able to
make available to to non-customers that
was all I see yeah um sorry I I
misunderstood what you that was that was
what I was saying I was saying uh are we
looking at potentially working with
businesses to add to the offer of public
toilet facilities that was all I think
um it that's quite difficult
I I think for cuz there are a lot of
cafes and and that don't want people
just walking in and out there without
without spending their money and so um
but I I I'll happy to discuss that and
I'll see discuss with officers to see
whether there is a way forward with that
thank you thank
you all right thank you uh members
CES thank you leader um yes this brings
me back to about 5 years ago because uh
councelor Whitehead and myself were
outside TDC offices at a toilet protest
when the Margate Clock Tower toilets um
ended up being
closed um so under similar to counselor
Austin I'm a
portaloo
uh I'm I'm like portaloo spotter I would
say um so often when I'm cycling along
Margate SE font I'm seeing how many Port
too we have in the summer do we have the
same as last year how busy are they and
asking officers um for more or for them
to be extended on for longer if the
Summer's um getting longer so I'm really
happy that we've got um the Margate
locked out toilets in writing it's
getting the funding um and also the
annex 2 is so such a good high level
document showing which toilets have been
considered which are in the longterm
plan which are being done now um and
where the funding is my my only question
I guess is I know and this is a question
that all the business businesses and
Margate would love the answer to do we
know when uh the clock tower toilets
might get refurbished
thanks yeah uh thank you councelor y I
think um you the clock tower toilets
will be one of the three um major refs
you or major um projects along with um
you know Stone Bay and I think um we're
looking at not this coming season we're
looking at uh the 20 during 2025 it's a
bit early to put a precise program on it
because of the scale of the works and
the required procurement and what have
you but uh yeah 2025 would be an
estimate at the
moment okay
members no further discussion I'm going
to read the recommendations which is
going to take a little while so you have
to bear with me that's why
I um cabinets as to approve the schedule
of works the report suggests in 3.1
stroke 3.2 either option one or option
two dependent on the outcome of
discussions with Southern water which
will be undertaken using £400,000 of the
funding from ount reserves under option
one 279,000 will be allocated for
Revenue repairs and
121,000 revenue contribution to Capital
under option two the whole £400,000 will
be allocated to revenue repairs 450,000
of capital funding by borrowing on 4
,000 from the Margate Town deal funding
external
Grant cabinet recommends to council that
a oneoff supplementary general fund
Revenue budget of 279,000 be approved
for the repairs to existing facilities
to be funded from an underspend
identified at the end of 22 20 22 23 and
allocated to eart reserves for
investment in toilet
facilities endorses the proposed
financing of the existing
$749,000 budget for the public toilets
refurbishment and renewal project within
the 2023 24 Capital program to be a mix
of £450,000 of borrowing A1 121,000
contribution from ear Mar reserves with
financing of the remaining 179,000 to be
identified at a later date with the
actual financing of the capital program
being determined by the section1 officer
as per officer
delegations recommends to council that a
supplementary general fund budget
capital budget of 250,000 be approved
for the refurbishment of of existing
botney Bay toilets subject to the
outcome of discussions with Southern
water for funding to the value of
250,000 approves a budget varment to be
made if the discussions with Southern
water are not successful as per option
two with a varment of 121,000 from the
budget for the revenue contribution to
Capital to be transferred to the revenue
budget for repairs to existing
facilities notes the 400,000 of approved
capital budget is allocated for toilet
facilities within the Margate Town deal
scheme in the 2324 Capital
program um requests a further report be
taken to Cabinet before the end of
October 20124 which provides an update
on toilet refurbishment and Improvement
Works including the outcome of the
Southern water Financial contribution
the report should also propos next steps
to address refurbishment or improvements
at the public toilets not included in
inial in this initial phase and finally
that the Western under cleared public
toilets be added to the dist of toilets
for consideration when further funding
becomes a available do members agree
AG I'm glad about that I'm not going to
read it
again thank you members um item Eight Is
the tenant and Lease holder Services
procurement responsive repairs voids
compliance and planed and cyclical Works
contract which is councelor
Whitehead thank you leader uh firstly I
would like to apologize to everyone
present cuz I think it's fairly certain
that I'm not known for my brevity but
this is a particularly long one because
because it's a very very complic complex
topic so can cabinet is tonight being
asked to authorize the following the
letting of a 10-year contract with
provision to extend for a further 5year
period to enable a true alliance between
contractors and client this contract is
for the provision of responsive repairs
voids compliance cyclical and planned
works it will also include an element of
works for corporate
properties the contract will cover
responsive repairs voids compliance
cyclical and planned works as listed
will provide an element of service for
the council's corporate properties we'll
provide an out ofour service for
emergency repairs and will'll maintain a
customer contact center for tenants and
Lease holders of the council to call to
report
repairs in developing this contract we
have placed a strong focus on local
delivery directly employed local
operatives and the use of local material
suppliers we did the this to add social
value to the area through jobs and
Material supplies provide the most
efficient and responsive delivery
through local Supply ensure that thanet
service is given priority through area
buyin and local knowledge and to
minimize carbon emissions by reducing
travel time for operatives and material
delivery the level of work that goes
into both procurement and organization
of a housing service of this scale is
extraordinary as is the progress that
has been made within housing since we
brought it back in house
our current contract was last extended
in
2020 it cannot be extended further which
means that coming in this may as an
Administration gives little to no lead
time to produce an extended in-house
service across all areas much as as
evidenced by my determination to bring
housing back and produce in-house
temporary housing and our first in-house
rough sleeping accommodation my general
inclination is to create and promote
in-house Services wherever
possible ideals always have to be
considered in relation to realities in
order to deliver results and the
security of service especially when what
is at stake is the quality of delivered
service to a very large number of our
residents uh such focusing on areas that
we can deliver in house such as minor
works and ensuring that our complex and
specialist areas function and deliver
without interruption is
essential as referenced in the report we
are now choosing to focus heavily on the
local economy and housing procurement
our contracts prioritize local jobs
local call center and include the
requirement for local apprenticeships to
build not only the local economy but
also build skills and employment
opportunities this combined with our
proposed in-house expansion of minor
Works to explore our delivery of Direct
Services allows us to deliver not only
many highly complex work streams but
also build our own
resilience and the sheer scale of the
number of new strategies being
implemented and the considerable growth
of our portfolio means that ensuring
reliability of provision at a time when
we are still a council with
disproportionately low stuffing for the
scale of what we deliver means that
considering the long-term future of all
projects is essential and testing the
water in terms of In-House provision is
a vital part of
this the service that now requires
procurement is currently being delivered
by MIRS through a 9-year partnering term
contract this contract is due to expire
on the 31st of March 2025 and due to the
complexity of this contract officers
have started this exercise now to ensure
that the right partnering contractor is
found ensuring that we Source a
contractor that fits the council's ethos
and
culture since the tenant and leaseholder
service was brought in house officers
have ensured strong contractor
management and have worked in true
partnership with MIRS this has reaped
rewards of improved customer
satisfaction and performance that can be
seen in the number of responsive repairs
that are completed on time
and the driving down of the Void
turnaround
times with only 5 years left on the
mir's contract at the point of
transition the stability of the service
and the issue of non-compliance with
regulatory and legislative factors took
logical priority over the exploration of
potential options to replace the
services of a partnering
contractor in preparing for this
procurement guidance has been sought
from a consultant that had a wealth of
experience in this area they conducted a
series of stakeholder workshops to
assess what is needed and valued within
the service their report recommends
continuing with the same model of
Service
delivery in moving forward we will apply
Lessons Learned From the current
contract keep a strong focus on local
delivery and the employment and training
of local
operatives it is proposed to continue
the service in this way because this
approach supports the management of the
Peaks and troughs of workload through
seasonal demand management of the risk
of sub contract is going into
liquidation and the management of two
appealer
obligations other positive aspects
include this being a model that is
supported by residents that we can use
this contract to tap into specialist
areas without carrying out lengthy
procurement
exercises and that a part partnering
contractor can onboard smaller local
contractors that local Authority
procurement regulations make difficult
for smaller companies to compete
for we have seen that this model works
well with the ripe contract management
and willingness to nurture the
partnership to the benefit of both
parties this can be evidenced through
the increases and the levels of customer
satisfaction when asked in 2021 and then
again in 2023 for Resident satisfaction
with the way TDC deals with repairs and
maintenance residents gave us the
following
statistics in 2021 63.4% of residents
Express satisfaction with the service in
2023 77.7 5% of residents Express
satisfaction with the
service this is nearly a 15% increase in
satisfaction in 2 years and we are
currently heading towards upper quartile
performance When comparing with other
social housing landlords which is
something that we should be hugely proud
of as a department and as a
council in relation to the second lot
included in this procurement officers
have calculated the work required to
decarbonize the council's housing stock
will cost in the region of 440
million we are therefore proposing to
include procurement for a bid and
delivery partner for Grant funded
works the rationale behind this proposal
is due to experience gained from our
Tower block retrofit and refurbishment
program when grant funding becomes
available to the sector we have to be
ready to bid and deliver the works
within very tight time
frames there is4 million per year
included for this element but this will
not be spent unless Grant fun funding is
available and a winning application is
made this level of spending has been
included because our Ambitions are to
decarbonize the housing stock provide
warm and comfortable homes for residents
and achieve this at the best possible
value as evidence by previous in-house
Investments within housing we are
interested in exploring which parts of
our services work effectively
in-house over the next couple of years
further work will be carried out to see
if a direct labor organization is the
right model model for TDC for the
long-term
future as mentioned at the beginning of
my introduction this already includes
extension of provision of some of our
in-house services this would include
minor Works fencing and arborist
works we intend to keep these services
available to call off throughout this
contract as well to provide resilience
to the service and to explore our
potential for delivery in a safe and
managed
way the implementation of a DLo is a
massive undertaking that would provide a
very important Frontline service
therefore must not be rushed and could
not be effectively produced within 6
months the principal issue is not the
creation of a DLo or otherwise it is the
management of whichever model is chosen
and the time and consideration put into
its
development exploring in-house work
incrementally and providing safety to
explore options within a secure
framework provides the Best of Both
Worlds informed by our knowledge of our
housing stock and our needs as an
area we must be sure that the chosen
model fits tdcs Athos culture and is
right for the tenants and Lease holders
tenants and Lease holders have expressed
support for the chosen model and we
strongly believe that we can Implement a
local Focus linking to our priorities
and strategy through this form of
delivery the budget for this service
comes from the housing revenue account
the HRA is separate from the general
fund and is self- financing through
rental and other income generated by H
owned land and property and therefore is
not supported by by tax
income it is very important the value
for money is obtained for the
h the value of this contract is £6
million but only if it was to be spent
in full and let for the full 15-year
duration this maximum equates to an
estimate of just under 11 million per
year £4 million of this per year is set
aside for Grant funded opportunities and
will only be
spent sorry only be spent if such
opportunities arise and if bids are
successful once the corporate aspect of
the contract has been removed and the £4
million per year for Grant funded
Capital works the contract value is
nearer 6.7 million per year this is
2,200 per property per year including
void Works responsive repairs and
allowances for planned and cyclical
works this value is based on the
previous year's spend and the consultant
has provided a cost model that shows
that this value is within the industry
Norm there was a lengthy discussion of
this procurement at on and a
recommendation was made to explore
performance related pay and explore the
ability to lock in a performance related
element to look at this further officers
have carried out the recommendation to
explore performance related pay and link
to research undertaken are proposing to
not implement this within the
contract the reasons for not including
this element within the contract are
Financial incentives can skewer the
contractor's performance towards certain
areas of the contract at the expense of
others a contractor May focus on the
areas they need to ensure they perform
in to maximize income and could neglect
other
areas contractors can potentially spin
key performance indicators referred to
his kpi from this point on to support
good performance to gain the
incentive the focus for the contractor
becomes achieving the kpi to receive the
incentive rather than consistent quality
over the entire ire
service disagreements can arise if both
parties do not agree on if a payment
should be awarded and it often does not
lead to True partnership working by
taking the performance related incentive
out of the discussion we can improve the
quality of the
service the success of a partnership
relies on clear objectives robust ke
performance indicators and a commitment
to continuous
Improvement we will be ensuring that the
contract allows robust Performance
Management via the following
producing a well- defined scope and
objectives of the contract ensuring both
parties have a mutual understanding of
their
responsibilities measurable kpis that
align with TDC strategic
objectives regular performance reviews
that create a collaborative environment
for feedback and
Improvement where performance is poor
and does not improve with these measures
there is the allowance through the
contract to apply a service improvement
plan and if performance is not improved
lead to a break clause for that service
element meaning that we can remove that
element of work and procure our own
Contra this in itself is a financial
incentive because if the partner
partnering contractor loses elements
from the scope of work their income will
be
reduced a huge amount of work has gone
into the preparation of this procurement
exercise and Mr Sullivan and the team
have worked incredibly hard her
commitment and expertise to overview and
scrutiny was exceptionally clear and is
recognized by all in housing I move the
recommendation set out in the report and
thank you everyone for bearing with
me um thank you councelor Whitehead I
don't think anyone could accuse you of
not being thorough as
usual um but it is an important subject
um and I note that you know I I viewed
remotely the um lengthy discussion that
went on at scrutiny which I think was
valuable um and useful and um I thought
there were some some excellent responses
and explanations there from from
officers and from yourself so I think
that it has been properly explored even
though nobody's chosen to come forward
and speak on it tonight so a second for
the recommendation thank you CC Yates
members you any
comments okay so the um the
recommendation the recommendation is for
the letting cabinets asked authorize the
letting of a 10-year contract with
provision to extend for a further 5year
period to enable a true alliance between
contractors and client this is to the
provision of responsive repairs voids
compliance cyclical and plan works the
contract will also include an element of
works for corporate properties members
agree agree thank you and we move on to
item nine which is the tenant lease
holder service key performance
indicators quarter 1 and quarter 2
housing performance report councilor
W thank you
leader this report provides members of
the cabinet with a review of the perform
performance of the council's tenant and
Leisa holder service TLS for quarter 1
and 2
2324 it includes performance information
relating to two areas of
TLS these are operational performance
against key indicators for the period
1st of April 2023 to 31st of June 2023
and 1st July 23 to September 23 and the
management of tenant and leas holder
health and safety as of 31st June and
31st September
23 as evidenced by the thorough nature
of these reports a huge amount of work
goes into both collecting and analyzing
data within housing and the
comprehensive coverage of our
performance is something that I believe
officers involved deserve significant
credit
for I would like especially to praise
the new dashboard style reporting which
I believe makes information more
accessible and very clear to understand
and also welcome the inclusion of
in-depth reporting on our tow block
retrofit and refurbishment program this
is a huge piece of work that is already
included an inclusive and comprehensive
resident consultation an inclusion of
this as a separate work stream is
exceptionally positive as I believe this
is of interest to both residents and
members I'm heartened that gas
compliance only has one outstanding case
and that this is linked solely to very
complex access issues as this indicates
the level of effort we have made and are
making to ensure that we are protecting
residents the drop in tenant aers is
extremely positive considering the level
of financial stress that many residents
are currently facing and I believe this
says a huge amount about the support
that our team are giving to Residents to
help them access support that they may
be entitled to and support them when
times are
challenging our work in relation to
voids is also very pleasing faster
turnaround times mean more families
accommodated more quickly which is
essential to reduce disruption to
families and provide secure
accommodation as quickly as
possible Mrs Sullivan's reports are
always very thorough and this is no
exception I want to recognize all of the
work that goes into cating and
presenting this information and extend
my thanks to Mr Sullivan and all
involved thank
you so you're moving that we note the
report I'm
moving sorry microphone on I'm moving
that we note the is there a
second well everybody wants to do that c
there second of the report members any
comments
no okay and
I'd like to thank um Mr and the team for
the report because I think that one of
the most satisfying things over the
recent period of this council is the way
that we've moved on from East Kent
housing and I think you know we are very
proud of our housing team in in all its
aspects um and uh in respect of the the
TLs service in particular but
um we're excited by the work that's
being done and look forward to more of
it so members that's agreed media thank
you and that concludes tonight's meeting
at uh
8:10 live stream the meeting will now
end thank you to members and officers
for their attendance
participation